you wrote the cover story on Mark
Zuckerberg brads on our recent cover
story on Travis kalanick you're like the
uber you're the unicorn of turtle I
think we've been killing as a beating us
all thank you let's start with it let's
start at the summit and how you compiled
this list and and the speaker list today
because I mean it's a killer lift these
are people that are really tough to get
I mean basically we start back in
February March just brainstorming we
like call every smart person we know and
say like who has the most influence and
we're thinking about sort of business
influence and also like cultural
influence um and we just sort of start
winnowing down and and then there's the
the secret sauce that goes into final
ranking but airport yeah exactly the
dark forward um and yeah and there you
have it and we were you know fortunate
enough to get a lot of these people to
show up and and do live conversations
yeah I really thought your piece on Mark
Zuckerberg and hockey lyst wasn't
critical think because it had so much
detail that even we didn't know um talk
to me about writing that piece and um
meeting mark and hearing this vision for
virtual reality which nobody else have
seen it's so interesting I mean there's
there's so much to talk about but um it
gives you a sense of how expansive marks
vision for facebook is because you look
at whatsapp or Instagram those are
acquisitions that sort of fit in to a
vision of Facebook that's very narrow
and then you look at something like
virtual reality and it isn't an obvious
fit but he's sort of transition to this
mode where he's thinking way way ahead
um and and then you have a two billion
dollar acquisition for a virtual reality
that was way way pretty fraud are you a
believer and how do you think we're
gonna be using virtual reality when
we're old I think uh I think the jury's
kind of out I think that in the next few
years are gonna start seeing on
airplanes for sure I think people gamers
in their homes you're gonna start seeing
it um I think maybe you know 20 years
from now some business meetings things
like that I don't think we're gonna plug
in to the matrix like thing anytime soon
although there are people at the
Facebook campus who are thinking along
those lines at least what do you think
that highlights are have been so far
today
and into tomorrow um so for me the Lena
Dunham watching Lena Dunham and Kevin
Systrom of Instagram sort of talk about
both the platform and how it's changed
in the culture was fascinating I think
Lena may be made a little news when she
dissed Twitter she is she has done over
and over but yes she said recently she
was gonna stop using Twitter but then
she still uses it um I got Vienna
surrogate she said she emails just
someone who tweets at her behalf um I
thought watching the bubble panel was
very interesting I mean it was kind of
gloomy I actually hadn't quite
appreciated just how many it seemed like
a lot of people were we're feeling dark
and and and that was sort of new to me
why do you think people are so consumed
by this question of whether we're in a
bubble I mean there are cyclical up
turns and down turns like clockwork it's
inevitable it's interesting because
normally the sign of a bubble is no
one's talking about the bubble so maybe
maybe there's some kind of
counterintuitive thing where we could
decide that you know party on based on
this by the way your boss Graydon Carter
actually came on earlier said absolutely
we are in a bubble so he called it yes
well uber your fast company headline was
something along the lines of why we all
love uber are you sure are you so sure
that's true have that is that ready is
it time for them to make their victory
lap right now i think that the that uber
is a really really useful service and
that and that there's there's been so
much negative press but when you just
take a few steps back and look how
amazing the company's growth has been
and how life-changing it has been um you
know it's just it's just remarkable
there there aren't too many companies
like it I mean I think it's on the level
of Facebook in terms of max captain of
Vanity Fair thank you so much